Logan Paul and Shaka for learning this
about Andrew Tate can we please invite
Andrew Tate on and have him no no no no
no I I've changed my my my my mind about
education and I'll tell you what oh not
the same way I'll tell you I'll tell you
why because we this guy can dance his
ass off oh yeah
bro you didn't know Andrew Tate's a
dancer oh wow that's how he got so
flexible with kickboxing and stuff was
he used to dance show me some dancing
moves I love you you actually didn't
know that no well I'm learning something
new I'm so excited we'll have to talk
about it we're gonna do it I'm gonna
make him dance with me yeah let's go
he's a good dancer it actually is him no
no no no he taught me how to do look
look dude he's been crushing look at
this that is not him he's destroying it
and he makes he makes videos like these
all the time in between the top G stuff
but like look
even in boxing in the gym
no no no people underestimate really how
capable Andrew Tate is my man can shake
that ass well you know what it is
dancing dancing people don't realize it
but dancing is extremely technique
driven like there are so many tiny
little things that you have to do in
order to be a good dancer and so was
kickboxing so there so they have this
Common Thread and it doesn't surprise me
that he studied a dance in order to
become a better kickboxer I love it yeah
and no one's even saying anything about
it this one because I'm talking about
when you get down in the club and you
got a boogie he's more ready to go than
anybody else oh my gosh
that's it new life girl dancing Easy
Money ripped and he can dance it's like
how do you not get girls and he plays an
instrument like come on chess come on
hey Andrew after finding out his IG got
deleted no worries he's dancing in his
room
are you going to put these on screen or
you're just going to look at the phone
wow that's a little much you guys
genuinely hate him no no what the [ __ ]
no oh because I I [ __ ] with a lot of the
[ __ ] he says no obviously dude you're a
racist a homophobic Christian
obviously you do no shut up shut up stop
and you hate women you think women are
inferior to men yeah of course 100
that's not even a joke my girlfriend
wait that's what pisses me off I
couldn't tell you a little racist
homophobic Christian he's an atheist
it's like you know what let him we'll
just keep listening no the part yeah
well let's keep listening but you know
the part that of me that's working to be
a better question just lets them say
okay say what you want about us say what
you want go ahead run your mouth [ __ ]
bird because in the end he's not she
doesn't have anything to do and she is
him she's no she's a woman in the
kitchen we just talked about this not
too far I took it too far bro he's a
troll bro
sometimes he does say good things we
agree with that I changed my I already
told Aiden Ross I've always been on that
Top Gear [ __ ] Ada Ross is in Dubai right
now always Tate uh they've been hanging
out [ __ ] I don't know in in all
reality all he does is just not funny I
don't know why Aiden sits there and just
and just I think I think they're talk
[ __ ] to me
that's the thing it's just not funny
he's trying to be funny right obviously
he's trying to make a joke because you
know Aiden Ross right a little pudgy
pudgy should I yeah the dude that
um Tate always calls with the LA
streamer kid that's a little pudgy Aiden
no offense Aiden I'm sure you're
wonderful I don't know who you are pudgy
that's what they call him but Tate's
just like inspiring him and helping him
become a better man so it's funny it's
cool to watch it's cool but you know
Logan's a hater I told Aiden before he
went out there I said yo you tell Tate I
want to [ __ ] you tell that [ __ ] thing
like that's like that's like a 12 year
old joke that's what I'm saying it's
like how is this a whole podcast of
these jokes it's just I don't get it
I've lost so much respect for for Logan
it was like down here and then it went
up to here when he was coming up on his
like Redemption Arc and then now after
all the Tate stuff nobody has respect
for him anymore and he just keeps
digging a hole for himself it's crazy
you tell him that I I think that the I
think our approach was a little I think
we our approach was a little bit
I'm in between if he was all of those
things why would you have him on the
podcast yeah I know you're joking but
it's just like I I just don't think
they're good jokes and he's just being a
hater no they're not good jokes I like
to think that I have a good funny meter
and I can tell what's funny and what's
not yeah this isn't ticking this isn't
this isn't taking any boxes on the funny
meter I mean maybe maybe he's got we got
a few minutes left of watching this
maybe he'll get a giggle we'll see good
luck Logan give you my crypto wallet
forget it I'll give you my crypto wallet
if we get a giggle out of him Andrew if
you're watching this invite me on I'd
like to have a conversation with you
one-on-one I would love to actually like
ask him legitimately because he's such a
[ __ ] because you're a matrix
notice how much more tame he is ever
since he got let back on social media
he's back on he's a [ __ ] hypocrite
he's back on social media and you will
not I promise you will not hear him
saying any of the outlandish [ __ ] that
he was saying in the past the [ __ ] that
got him are you saying any of the
outlandish [ __ ] you said in the past
Logan are you glass houses throwing
stones I got I gotta I gotta step in I
don't think he was ever kicked off bro I
never seen more of him than when he got
here those are the other Pages
no but I'm saying he has like his own
little that's all that's ever been is
the fan pages he had an Instagram that
wasn't even that popping for his actual
virality it looks like he's in a dungeon
I don't know where he's at but he's
smoking cigars with his brother but dude
it's always on my feed listen if if
anybody got canceled like that then like
canceling is not even know anything
anymore okay uh the the economics of
being de-platformed are actually
incredibly favorable to the person who
got the platform we know that okay so I
so I see I see what you're saying and
you're right well he made it back he it
was it's
he did in a really interesting time
where Elon took over and was like oh you
we didn't agree with what you've done in
the past well that's fine you're allowed
back so in a way
it was like he got a free life like
essentially no he got he got plus one
oh no Mike made me
laughing
not you oh well that wouldn't make sense
you're the only one making me laugh
right now you could just laugh and then
I'd have to give you my crypto wallet
honestly get from my crypto
and he was like good
and Luigi came back and was like I'm
back [ __ ] you Mario you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you I'm gonna post a picture of you
getting sprayed with a [ __ ] hose on a
boat look at all fat and stupid and Eli
was like I heard Mario was like okay
I'd like to just say to all the people
who watch this religiously find some new
content I've yet to see anything of real
like intellectual value and everything
doesn't have to be an intellectual
Pursuit but if you are going to be
wasting your time on the internet I mean
with the walk away a better human being
walk away smarter walk away like at
least with better wit something a
motivation something this is not even
this is empty I'd rather frankly watch
the Kardashians fight about pantyhose
Mike I would come off again bro well the
reason I say the tape [ __ ] is because
maybe it's because of what you're saying
now he is like he hasn't been like oh
it's funny how that works no but maybe
you're right I don't know
[ __ ]
because guess what bro guess what I
thought you're saying that to me no
guess what what
I beat that ass
hey there if you like the clip make sure
I did not like the clip again pretty
eyes just take pictures and shut your
mouth all right thank you guys so much
for watching make sure to like subscribe
join the Discord and follow me on
Instagram at sunnyfast post a bunch of
free sauce on my Instagram story it's
lit thank you free sauce free sauce what
does that mean
[Music]
s
[Music]